ask yourself this if a tree falls in the
forest does it make a sound answer who
the [ __ ] cares Oh what is going on
YouTube this is now if you've ever had
roommates there will come a time where a
few then will get under your skin
because sooner or later you are going to
realize that certain friends can be
roommates but other friends should just
you know oh my god because you know
there are five types of roommates that
you hate so you already know what it is
LTI penny let's get let's go number one
the not my dishes roommate why is it
that every time you ask hey can you do
your dishes without fail the response is
it ain't mine this roommate is the
person that no matter how many times you
have seen them eat in front of you it is
never his dishes I threw away all my
dishes and got new ones I didn't eat
today yo [ __ ] don't do dishes alright
this is Raisin in the Sun [ __ ] I know
do no dishes Oh cuz I'm black I'm
supposed to do dishes huh oh yes massa
dude yea yea it's like that huh I know
all y'all out there know it's going to
get at that point but they get the balls
to say that it's actually not theirs
it's yours you need to clean your dishes
why you always blame me and shakey be
yours yo you put this in to see
yesterday I don't know what the [ __ ]
you're talking about doc you yokozuna
honey
number two leave the lights on
everywhere roommate this [ __ ] oh my god
for some reason no matter if its life or
dark this fool has to turn on the light
everywhere he goes
what the [ __ ]
listen nobody has a problem with you
using the lights that's what you're
supposed to do but [ __ ] you ain't
Batman what you need a spotlight for and
then how are you going to be the main
source for our electricity bill
but then complain about the price you
are the electricity bill and simple
you'll leave the room you turn on the
lights when you leave the house you're
turn off the lights when you go to sleep
put you a grown-ass man still offense
done [ __ ] number three the never takes
out the trash
roommate how is it possible that both of
us took out the trash last time it's
either me or you then gone and before
you even come back with that remark oh
my god you never she got the trash even
if none of us take out the trash then
how does it magically disappear huh I am
the only one who takes out the trash and
you want to know why cuz you [ __ ]
suck and everything else you leave the
lights on you don't do the dishes so why
the [ __ ] would you ever take out the
trash you know what else these fools
will do they will see a full garbage can
but it's this taking out the trash
they will play garbage Tetris and you
know how they lie cuz when you ask me
the exact date they start to stutter me
[ __ ] yeah and was the last time you pick
up the trash Nana
yo y'all got there right yeah that's
alright brother and that's our keeper
hey shut the [ __ ] up
not before they let random people sleep
over roommates do not get me started how
many times have you caught that fool
telling someone oh you kidding me Jovan
check out the pain yeah man you can
sleep at my place yeah you sleeping in
his room and you notice the person who
usually has a [ __ ] to the people come
over is the one who pays the least
amount of rent there's a guy just put
this out there
barely afford your room although [ __ ] do
you think you are
do we look like the grand Budapest hotel
mother [ __ ] unless they pay in rent
contributing to our crib and they are
not staying here more than two weeks
I'll play stay looking like immigration
and [ __ ] and half the Targa's not even
people that you know oh he'll get you on
our side
what's up yo who the [ __ ] is this dude
over here man [ __ ] that is it you don't
know what oh never fine the never pay
rent on time roommates now you know when
you sign the lease it stated that you
had to pay rent every month so tell me
why is it that somehow every first of
the month you get diagnosed with amnesia
Khalif what rent oh my god no you know
no you're not doing that an octopus
what's that gotta do with rent and why
is it that it's always the roommate who
don't got money that's buying new [ __ ]
every month talking about whoa yo I got
this new guitar gasps Natasha yo I'm
diggin my [ __ ] my [ __ ] whoa hey you
know what I'm pretty lenient because
sometimes you can cut up on hard times
and you can't pay rent I got you but
[ __ ] you are the first person on earth
that got rent on layaway
oh it's like what spit oh it's like a
plow baptism